welcome to hannity tonight democrats
they've been in charge of congress the
white house for just
16 days and as predicted their own
vindictive
radical extreme agenda is now taking
center stage
in that swamp as we speak the byte
administration now is quickly
implementing
aoc's insane green new deal agenda
destroying tens of thousands of
high-paying career jobs in the process
all with the stroke of a pen signing now
47
executive orders and actions which is
over two and a half times more than
obama
bush and clinton combined now meanwhile
next week the u.s senate is set to hold
another pointless vicious
unconstitutional
impeachment shift show it serves no pers
purpose the outcome is predetermined
other to vent
their rage and to smear president donald
trump
in exile one last time and in the house
democrats are waging a campaign against
an obscure republican freshman lawmaker
who has been on the job for one month
and one day
joe by the way if you're still awake if
you're still with us now
you're leading the country with great
unity got to give you applause for that
and tonight during a house wide vote
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene was
stripped of all committee assignments
because of things that she has said some
conspiracy theories we talked about last
night that she floated
before getting elected house democrats
went ahead with their punitive measures
even though congresswoman taylor green
has now disavowed
her previous beliefs and conduct during
an unscripted speech
on the house floor today let's take a
look
when i started finding misinformation
lies things that were not true
in these q and on posts i stopped
believing it
and i want to tell you any source and i
say this to everyone
any source of information that is a mix
of truth and a mix of lies is dangerous
you see school shootings are absolutely
real
and every child that is lost those
families mourn it
i also want to tell you 9 11 absolutely
happened
i remember that day crying all day long
watching it on the news
and it's a tragedy for anyone to say it
didn't happen
and so that i definitely want to tell
you i do not believe that it's fake
these were words of the past and these
things do not represent me
i'm glad the congresswoman delivered
that speech but ultimately for democrats
this is not
at all about marjorie taylor greene a
new congresswoman
instead it's a mere political ploy the
idea they want to smear
all conservatives all republicans as
extreme conspiracy theorists and over
almost every single sanctimonious
democrat devoted today
they're all guilty of the biggest hoax
the biggest conspiracy
the the lies that they've told for three
straight years that's right the big
trump russia collusion lie
they have put this country through hell
for three years
and everything they told the american
people
was false now working in support of the
big lie they have their allies their
press office we refer to them as the
media mob
and listening to these lying trump
russia collusion
truthers running non-stop wall-to-wall
coverage
of the marjorie taylor green saga it's
pretty sickening marjorie taylor green
she apologized she said her beliefs were
wrong misguided
she doesn't have them today so my
question is
when are the democrats going to follow
suit when will the media mob apologize
and correct the record on so many
stories they all got wrong
here's my prediction hell you know down
there
will freeze over first don't hold your
breath
they're feigning their pony outrage as
usual and play
acting like this is the most important
story of our time
it's not the congresswoman green she
doesn't set the agenda
for the republican party the way the
radical squad
led by the real speaker of the house
congresswoman
ocasio-cortez does for the democratic
party
few people know congresswoman greene i
don't know a conservative or republican
that supports or condones those past
beliefs that she disavowed today
the real story here is that democrats
have now opened the floodgates
with an alarming new precedent
apparently voters
and elections they no longer matter to
them
according to those who voted to remove
congresswoman greene from committees
a standard they won't apply to
themselves the people in
georgia those that voted for her by a
whopping 74 percent of the vote
don't matter to the people that voted
today think about that
their votes just discounted lawmakers
outside of her district they're calling
the shots including
many truly insane conspiratorial
democrats
the ones that have never apologized for
their past radical views
anti-semitic statements and so much more
we'll have more in a moment
now members of congress can apparently
be penalized and stripped of important
committee assignments for something
that they once believed and hours ago
congressman jim jordan
asked this all-important question who's
next
take a look who's next
who is next everyone has said things
they wish they didn't say
everyone has done things they wish they
didn't do
so who's next who will to cancel culture
attack next today it's miss green who's
it going to be tomorrow
who's it going to be tomorrow i've heard
several times on the floor today from
the democrats
conspiracy theory the democrats peddled
the biggest conspiracy theory
of all time the russia hoax now come to
think of it when republicans do take
back the majority they've got a pretty
good shot from my position here in 2022
there are plenty of conspiratorial
democrats they should be removed from
their committees right if we apply
standards equally
every democrat the push to trump russia
conspiracy theory the lies
they should all be stripped of their
committees if we're going to have a one
standard fits all
and as we pointed out last night
congresswoman ocasio-cortez
she told voters that the world was going
to end in 12 years
congresswoman omar tweeted once that
evil
israel is hypnotizing the world speaker
pelosi adam schiff
maxine waters dozens of others they all
pushed the russia lies
they openly speculated the 2016 election
was rigged
or stolen while ignoring hillary's
dossier
and ignoring what oh we now know on the
record about christopher steele and the
source
and that this was all russian
disinformation that hillary paid for
never wanted to comment on the truth
they said that the president of the
united states was
putin's puppet pretty crazy stuff
forgetting of course obama says tell
vladimir i'll have more flexibility
after the election
that doesn't even take into account
their violent inciting
insurrectionist language based on their
definition
that we have detailed on this program uh
many times
so mark my words tonight's today's
political stunt
it will backfire for democrats and
keeping with their governing theme
well this action does absolutely nothing
to improve the lives of you the american
people
this is nothing more than yet another
political ploy
and but by the way don't ask them to say
the pledge of allegiance why
because at the beginning of the
committee meetings well jerry nadler
said that would not be necessary
in his committee take a look in the
spirit of national unity and national
pride which i know we all aspire to
do to a greater extent that at the
beginning of each meeting
the chair or one of the designers of the
chair would have the opportunity to
lead us in the pledge of allegiance
we're all aware that
in these times it's important for the
country to see
members of congress working together on
some things i recognize myself to speak
in opposition to the amendment
um it's unnecessary the house
begins every day uh with the uh pledge
of allegiance
we're covered by that um there's no
necessity to say the pledge of
allegiance twice during the same day
it's interesting nadler's still awake
for this hearing